[Musica]
ecco io inizio con una frase di paolo
borsellino visto che sono stato
introdotto con una frase di giovanni
falcone così spiego anche la ragione
della mia presenza qui paolo borsellino
una volta disse rispondendo a una
domanda che lui non aveva chiesto di
occuparsi di mafia ci era entrato per
caso e poi c'era rimasto per un problema
morale la gente moriva attorno ecco io
non so non ho mai chiesto di occuparmi
di mafia ci sono entrato per caso dovevo
riempire 9 crediti sul piano di studio
all'università
e poi ci sono rimasto per un problema
morale mi vergognavo ad essere
antimafioso solamente il 23 maggio negli
anniversari delle stragi oggi inizio il
mio talk con questa panchina
questa è una normalissima panchina
probabilmente ne trovereste anche di più
belle lungo il tamigi di fronte alla
tech modena ma questa panchina la
particolarità che è la panchina sulla
quale ero seduto il 4 ottobre di quattro
anni fa quando in un particolare momento
della mia vita
decise di abbandonare una delle
università più prestigiose al mondo
perché non potevo studiare quello che
ero andato lì in teoria fare ovvero
studiare il ruolo geopolitico delle
mafie a livello internazionale perché lì
mi disse ruvido un cane una bottega
leasing è stretta
cioè non ci occupiamo dei ragazzi nelle
strade perché per loro la concezione era
che la mafia non sono altro che lega i
giovanile che hanno all
e nelle periferie di londra e io mi
contorcevano al fatto che non veramente
non mi capacitavo di come non capissero
le varie conseguenze a livello politico
economico sociale della presenza mafiosa
a livello locale nazionale ma
soprattutto a livello internazionale
poi traffici criminali con una
movimentazione di milioni di euro e per
allora lì da quello spaesamento ho
capito che in realtà il problema non era
neanche loro il problema era che non
avevano la conoscenza non sapevano come
conoscere quel problema e nonostante
tutto in italia nonostante tutti i
problemi non ne abbiamo 30 anni di
conoscenza di lotta alla mafia e deriva
anche dal sangue di molte persone che
hanno dato la vita per lottare contro la
mafia è da lì che è nata l'idea di voti
mafia cioè fare in ambito accademico
scientifico quello che in ambito
giuridico giudiziario aveva fatto rocco
chinnici col pool antimafia cioè
riorganizzare centralizzare mettere
tutta la conoscenza in un unico luogo
affidabile e comunicarlo in maniera
rapida e semplice a tutti perché per
questo facciamo permettere a chiunque in
maniera libera gratuitamente di
conoscere e comprendere un fenomeno
complesso come quello mafioso perché
alla fine questa guerra perché noi siamo
in guerra si può combattere solamente
con la conoscenza perché non potete
combattere ovviamente per forza di cose
un nemico quando non lo conoscete
nessuno andrebbe mai in guerra senza
conoscere il nemico
purtroppo molto spesso questo accade e
per farvi capire che cosa facciamo con
wiki mafia noi ultimato e alla lotta
alla mafia è una conseguenza noi
inizialmente io ho iniziato io e tutti
gli altri ragazzi che lavorano chiamati
abbiamo iniziato perché volevamo
difendere la bellezza di questo paese
perché nonostante tutto noi all'italia
ci teniamo e pensiamo che sia un
un paese in cui valga la pena vivere
tant è che siamo tornati io non sono
rimasto a londra sono tornato da milano
e quindi vi mostro questo tramonto
questo tramonto
voi potete ammirare a 40 km da milano e
in una cittadina montevecchia da cui
potete su una collina potete ammirare
tutta la brianza e lo skyline di milano
questo è un modo di vedere questo
tramonto lo scattato quest'anno 6
gennaio
e uno dei tanti modi però perché quello
che ho link compreso in quattro anni di
lavoro con wiki mafia che la realtà non
è mai quello che sembra perché anzitutto
la bellezza diverse prospettive ne
abbiamo già parlato prima come che c'è
bisogno di un cambio di prospettiva e
questo è un altro modo di vedere questo
tramonto
io l'ho chiamato l'occhio di dio perché
sono abbastanza artistico ma questo è un
modo di vedere lo stesso tramonto e ce
ne sono diversi i modi di vedere lo
stesso tramonto di cogliere la bellezza
in anche nelle piccole cose questo è un
dettaglio
eppure probabilmente la foto più bella
di quella precedente
eppure in questa foto dove scorgete la
bellezza di quel panorama
ma se in questa che in questa c'è il
male come direte il male se c'è il male
perché da quella collina voi vedete
quello stupendo panorama ma lì dentro in
quella parte scura che voi non vedete
perché chiaramente in tramonti alla
penombra del tramonto velo copre ci sono
colate di cemento che non sono diverse
da quelle che hanno devastato la conca
d'oro palermo c'è la ndrangheta che
spara che ammazza uccide distrugge il
futuro di migliaia di persone ma
soprattutto trovereste l'omertà non
diversa da quella che c'è magari a
corleone
perché quello che fanno questi signori
quando arrivano in un territorio non è
semplicemente quello di portare i loro
soldi poi i loro affari o i loro metodi
loro modificano la struttura genetica
della società e allora se ed è un
processo inarrestabile
perché come diceva giovanni falcone per
avere la mentalità mafiosa non è
necessario essere dei criminali infatti
quello che sta succedendo oggi è che la
mentalità mafiosa ha strabordato ed è
arrivata anche laddove tipicamente quel
fenomeno mafioso non ve lo aspetteresti
e non è da oggi da almeno 50 anni il
primo fatto di mafie lombardia risale al
1956 ed era legato al traffico di
diamanti
ci mettiamo anche questa balla per cui
la mafia esiste solo qui in sicilia no
sono dappertutto sono ovunque e voi
direte ma allora come facciamo a
sconfiggerli con la conoscenza perché
questo quello che ho imparato perché
solamente attraverso la conoscenza se
c'è una cosa che mi fa impazzire e
sapere che noi possiamo sapere ma
soprattutto sapere che il popolo si può
ribellare perché ci si può ribellare
come ci si ribella mostrandogli che
esiste un'alternativa al loro sistema di
potere è già successo perché come diceva
antonio gramsci la cultura è l'unico
modo che hanno le masse per ribellarsi
ai padroni e con la mafia non è diverso
e direte voi è facile a dirsi certo che
non è facile se fosse facile lo faremmo
tutti ed è qui che sta il problema però
ricordatevi sempre che per quanto
difficile possa essere si può sempre
fare qualcosa ad esempio guardare le
stelle piuttosto che i nostri piedi ad
esempio affrontarli a testa alta pensare
che vale la pena a spiccare il volo e
pensare una società diversa da quella
cui ci hanno costretto in non solo qui
in sicilia ma anche su al nord
questi signori invece che stare fermi e
pensare che oramai e 6mila abile che le
cose sono così che quindi debbano andare
così certo per cambiare le cose bisogna
pagare un prezzo eppure io penso che
quel prezzo sia giusto pagarlo anche se
ci sono dei rischi
adesso vi faccio vedere un'altra cosa
che abbiamo fatto con wiki mafia è una
delle cose più belle non l'ho fatta io
questa è la più grande sezione sul maxi
processo di palermo mai creata al mondo
sapete chi l'ha fatta l'ha fatta un
ragazzino di 17 anni tre anni e mezzo fa
che a scandale lasciato il suo tempo
libero ha investito il suo tempo libero
per tre mesi e ha realizzato questa voce
che è stata vista centinaia di migliaia
volte e ha informato tante persone
quindi quando dice che cosa posso fare
un ragazzino di 17 anni ha fatto questo
voi siete da meno questa anche la
bellezza l'impegno noi a ultima siamo
siamo tutti una grande famiglia hermes
thomas alessandro chiara adele tutti
siamo una famiglia ma non ci lega al
sangue ci regala convinzione la fede nel
fatto che la fine vinceremo noi perché
se i giovani si organizzano si
impadroniscono di ogni ramo del sapere
lottano a fianco dei lavoratori e degli
oppressi non c'è scampo per un vecchio
ordine fondato sul privilegio
sull'ingiustizia questi signori che voi
molto spesso definita eroe ho sentite
definire eroi
è questo il primo errore non erano eroi
non era né eroi che erano persone
normali come noi erano persone normali
come noi con le nostre delle loro
debolezze e anche i loro pregi ma quella
straordinarietà di quello che hanno
fatto non è stato morire perché la loro
straordinarietà non sta nella morte ma
sta nel fatto di come hanno vissuto nel
fatto che hanno ogni giorno fatto
semplicemente il loro mestiere con
onestà per questo non basta a fare la
lotta alla mafia non basta bisogna anche
farlo con lo stesso rigore la stessa
coerenza morale con cui lo fecero loro
perché i mafiosi possono anche vincere
tutte le battaglie giudiziarie essere
assolti per insufficienza di prove ma
c'è una battaglia che non vinceranno mai
ed è quella fondamentale per vincere la
guerra ed è la quotidiana battaglia che
ciascuno di noi ingaggio ogni mattina
col proprio specchio con la battaglia
noi abbiamo il dovere di non perderla
mai non per noi stessi ma per questo
sacrificio e ma soprattutto per quelli
che verranno dopo di noi perché noi non
siamo altro che semi loro li hanno
uccisi ma non li hanno uccisi veramente
sono suoi semi e ai nostri capelli ma
erano segni sono sbocciati wiki mafie ma
tema sono due strumenti sono due di quei
segni ed è per questo motivo che si può
sempre fare qualcosa voi pensate che
cosa posso fare io potete fare qualcosa
i piani regolatori di firmano gli
ingegneri e gli architetti i milioni di
euro che vengono movimentati per
paradisi fiscali movimentano operatori
finanziari laureati in economia
ed è una cosa assurda questa che i meno
l'università non se ne parli che come se
amicissimo di smettere di studiare il
cancro una roba assurda se ci pensate
una disciplina così ignorato una
malattia sociale così pervasiva che non
viene studiata
ecco perché facciamo quello che facciamo
ma voi potete fare qualcosa ad esempio
anche da semplici cittadini per esempio
non andando a comprare in determinati
posti o non dando il voto un politico
che ha chiacchierato non abbiamo bisogno
delle sentenze della magistratura si
saranno queste cose perché dobbiamo
sempre aspettare che arrivi la
magistratura si può già colpirli nel
tessuto vivo dei loro affari senza
bisogno di fare nulla se non
semplicemente il nostro dovere di
cittadini e professionisti e possono
esserci dei momenti di scoramento disco
in cui pensate perché non ne valga la
pena
mi è successo recentemente di pensarlo
era tutta una serie di vicissitudini
eppure ricordatevi sempre le parole di
un grande presidente della repubblica
che è stato anche partigiano che a
giovani come noi disse trent'anni fa
talvolta nella vita non è necessario
saper lottare solo senza paura ma anche
senza speranza così abbiamo difeso la
libertà e l'abbiamo riconquistata
ecco io dico che anche così oggi noi la
dobbiamo difendere questa libertà grazie
[Applauso]